[Musica]
ho qui con me e meno male perché non c'è
la voglia di essere impostare sincero
allora iniziò a seguire la gente siamo
io fede e qualcuno chi è che c'è le luci
mannaggia non si vede nulla e ora che
non faccio task sto in mezzo alla gente
perché voglio vedere che cosa fa la
gente allora è una squadra è un tridente
d'acciaio un report c'è un morto qua ok
perfetti la trovando la droga troilo e
dei power che siamo appena passati in
caffetteria lui bolchi armarlo ok niente
non ce n'era un altro con noi c'era un
altro io non ho chiesto power ho visto
lorenzo anche chi infatti non capisco
dove l'aspetta questa aspetta aspetta un
secondo in caffetteria comunque io ho
fatto caffetteria e sono andato a
navigation sia navigation e non ho visto
il corpo
e allora era sopra è comparso nei porti
libero davanti alla porta era lei che
mai amate che è morto il secondo dopo di
me è la seguente votarli votatemi ma nel
caso dei caratteri previsioni e power
hanno visto in telecamere io non l'ho
vista ragazzi tutto quando hanno
chiamato ora il cioè quando favi già
chiamato ora il cadavere to dovere di
precisare resta venite nella tasca di
whip on
da allora ragazzi forza se fosse passato
ma va bene io sto con loro e solo loro
[Risate]
abbiamo beccato step ambientato la droga
era qua non può non averlo visto ragano
io sto vicino a power
io sto veramente vicino a power il
problema e questo perché power è
veramente sicuro che non lo è
secondo so che siamo in due quindi uno
può parlare col all'altro e sto
veramente vicino a persone dello staff
ha le tasche
quindi se power si avvicina una mia
tasca tipo questa io la faccio
mannaggia qua siamo abbastanza persone
la potergli permettere di farla devo
trovare power ok perfetto meno male di
repower stiamo vicini bravo giorgio che
ha capito come funziona roba stiamo
vicini perché noi due sappiamo che non
lo siamo in attivo quali c'è seals bravo
sì ok io e power stiamo insieme vieni
che dobbiamo fissarle lui ci si aspetta
forse ciò fuel fare io so che c'è un
agli storage bene ma ho trovato un
cadavere era avrei già visto loro
insiste molto vicino cioè lorenzis basta
basta non esista veramente te sei tu che
non posso dire con 100 per cento che
fosse lui perché veniva da sinistra noi
siamo stati tutto il tempo insieme pure
quando palle signori un po d ordine per
favore un land andata via la luce io e
loro ci siamo mossi piano piano assieme
però bisogna essere
che voi siete sicuramente passati per lì
sotto perché siete andati sotto quindi
ma io a dover de amicis storage e quindi
non è passati ma c'era non c'era la luce
viene andato nelle security gamma ho
incrociato che noi e che stavo scendendo
verso sotto c'era fa vige nella stessa
stanza c'era gabbi e abbiamo visto tutti
e due il corpo nello stesso preciso
istante
guardami negli occhi lorenzo lo jury
lawrence giovano su tua madre io ho
paura possa scappare nulla loro ogni
voto balbettato votatelo problemi mi
avete votato quindi si fa vj non è 100
persone a meno che non siano paure fa
vice cavani in giro percettiva
ma che cosa andiamo li aspetta perso
fino con noi che vedevo che vedevo di
giorgio difendici io e giorgio non
possiamo essere ragazzi quindi e
qualcuno di non si sa chi è però io
le giornate a muoverci insieme perché
sennò maledetta che noia e che non ho
gli affidatevi fidatevi che che noia
fidatevi
raga che noi sa 8000 per cento che noia
che noia mille volte non so dove andare
la caduta vicino c'è gente che noia
aiuto madonna checa ragazzi ragazzi ho
appena visto fuori già a uccidere che
noia ragazzi basso visto farisei che
noia romani mori
fino ad ora sei un verso di me sei un
pezzo di merda fino ad ora sono stato
conti decisamente la stai giocando
no no no vabbè allora ce la mettiamo
allora bellissimo
non sono io te la sei giocata benissimo
perché adesso vi faccio vedere io sono
il colpevole hai cambiato fazione alla
fine fatto pregare che abbiamo vinto
movimenti abbiamo vinto a dare a noi ha
davanti a me rimarrà come dovete tra
star e propria novità ha paura anche
ciao ragazzi può album play ma perché
giorgio perché e giorgio mille per cento
ed era giorgio marco e voi vi fate
manipolare come di più da fare che vi
fate pure manipolare prevedere se c'e
una partita decente porca vacca
allora vediamo se riesco ad andare in
security a guardare la gente non voglio
essere io il primo a vedere che cacchio
cioè non voglio essere io il primo a
uccidere stavolta sto un pochettino a
perché me la voglio giocare attimo
guardo un po di gente ragazzi in
security perché devo crearmi degli alibi
deve sembrare che io stia facendo cose
abbastanza utile se non ha senso
praga visto questo marca passare da
quelle parti visto che per di fare lì ma
dopo ok io ho visto anche lorenzis è
partito l'ossigeno no mi sembra di sì
genoa ti ho visto io ero in caffetteria
a fare una tasca ho visto mark passare
per sotto e poi suonato sotto visto fare
morte ma pure lawrence mai visto l'ora
insiste ragazzi da quella parte terreno
era però davanti allo striano morta a
pianoro il se marchionne sono passati lì
davanti
allora io io ero in telecamere quindi
voglio sentire che dice
che diceva ma allora non si pone visto
dalle telecamere si lorenzo l'ho visto
però si fa e l'ho visto che andava però
sulla destra della mappa quindi verso
navigation mi pare però lui quindi è
passato davanti o 2 dove le presenze
cioè si vedevano davanti davanti sulla
sinistra no per ospiti power allora
allora insiste è il prossimo sono venuti
che se moriamo io e te allora passa mila
carte uguali per parlare abbiamo già
messo mille moria che era per capire
pure se lawrence in secondo marca ma
sarà lui
tenete d'occhio lorenzo va bene ragazzi
sono rimasto solo io e che è un mega
problema perché io da solo da solo
contro tutta sta gente è un problema
fidatevi ragazzi è un momento veramente
cruciale questo è un momento cruciale
perché
devo far sì che loro si ammazzino tra di
loro e quello fatto perché è proprio
questo il discorso è veramente questo
discorso
devo aspettando la se stessa mi sa che
provo a chiamare la la roba aiuto mai lo
farà io lo voglio fare vaio m a me
stesso mi fa paura ma allora allora
spesso mi sempre cosa vuoi da di morire
poi via da fernando dall'altra parte
quando abbiamo fatto le vertici sono
cagato addosso mi ha aspettato grillo se
qualcun altro po paura di morire erika
fonsai effetto allora senza paura ma
visto stranamente i rom oggi vorrebbero
che le camere mike raga no no io stavo
correndo va a fare l'emergency gol che
noi è riuscito ad admin vita e roma
carolina admin ha fatto ho strisciato la
carta sono uscito sondato verso giu e
stato come se stessero 23 secondi sono
risalito e cera che noia della parte
della botola ragazzi che ne so io
primati
abbiamo vinto insieme da impostori bello
sono però il rischio di un grado di
regalare un mazzo di fiori allora
insiste dopo ragazze non siamo qui a
caso mi avete ucciso sempre non mi
seguire ti prego se va bene
stanno tutti troppo vicini raga è quello
il fatto siamo tutti troppo vicini non
si può fa come uno si allontana non
siamo fa il discorso ragazzi scusate se
la spreca un po secolo mezzo è un
fantasma che non stava c'e nelle tasche
perché ce ne mancano letteralmente 2 a 3
e mangiavano più infido le quest io come
potevo seduto in telecamere i miei sette
marce bene marco e poi votiamo marta
voto dire no ma no fitness e stupido
votare
dai capi non è questo se i fantasmi
finiscono tutto ne mancano sei capi
uccisa power meno male ma io lanciato di
già chiuso ma non pensavo allora per me
meno male beh io rimango della mia idea
è che noi ha poi perso perche ho perso
la gara perché se power usciva adesso se
power fosse uscito io avrei vinto perché
poi nel round dopo gli avrei fatti tutti
il problema è che non siamo arrivati
abbastanza a bada abbastanza voti per
power e quindi ho perso e solo per
questo motivo cacchio che sfiga potevo
vincere mela da solo potevo veramente
vincer mela forse se riesco
c'era la ga ga bastardo eravamo io e
fabio de marchi e fare si tarda a quindi
praticamente io mi riguarda io poi per
ogni commento davvero
[Musica]